la lista del pacto histórico para
derrocar el régimen de la corrupción así
hablaba el político colombiano gustavo
petro en el nacimiento del pacto
histórico una coalición de partidos de
izquierda movimientos sociales y
ecologistas y con representación
indígena y afrodescendiente
esta unidad presentó el 19 de enero la
campaña para las elecciones del 13 de
marzo al senado y la cámara de
representantes
su cabeza de lista para el senado
gustavo bolívar contó en france 24 que
es el pacto histórico el pacto histórico
es una juntanza de partidos en oposición
que queremos ser opción de poder para
acabar con una cantidad de crisis que
nos deja este gobierno crisis
humanitaria crisis crisis en el empleo
crisis de violencia de violación de
derechos humanos que han sucedido
durante las últimas manifestaciones
el 13 de marzo también se decidirá quién
será el candidato presidencial de la
coalición los precandidatos van desde la
lideresa afro francia márquez la
defensora de derechos humanos indígena
wayú haré
el ex gobernador de nariño camilo romero
el pastor protestante alfredo sadel y el
favorito gustavo petro quien quedó en
segundo lugar en las elecciones
presidenciales de 2018 gustavo petro es
el candidato de la izquierda más
importante y más viable electoralmente
en la historia de este país
él es el líder indiscutible creo que es
claro que va a ser el candidato pero no
puede ganar solo tiene un techo porque
es una persona que de todas formas es
muy de izquierda para un país
relativamente conservador la coalición
ha tratado en todo momento de mantenerse
fiel a sus bases de una izquierda
diversa pero también busca ampliar
apoyos para ganar tejiendo alianzas con
políticos tradicionales que han cambiado
de colores políticos hasta llegar a la
izquierda eso necesariamente lo pone en
conversaciones con personas que su
digamos su base natural más fuerte
izquierda encuentra difícil trabajo ser
que su base a su base le cuesta trabajo
resignarse a tener que ampliar alianzas
con digamos personas más de centro o
candidatos cuestionados un equilibrio
entre los y la gobernabilidad para
conseguir después de varios intentos
frustrados en el pasado incluso con el
magnicidio de candidatos una mayoría en
el congreso y llevar a la casa de nariño
al primer presidente de izquierda en la
historia de colombia